stage 7 is something that is more or
less hypothetical that would be the
stage in which it's basically a
transient stage in which you understand
how you work and which the Mind fully
realizes how it's implemented and can
also in principle enter different modes
in which could be implemented and that's
the stage that as as far as I understand
is not open to people yet
oh but it is possible to the process of
Technology yes and who knows if there
are biological agents that are working
at different time skills than us that
basically become aware of the way in
which they are implemented on ecosystems
and can change that implementation and
have agency over how they implemented in
the world and what I find interesting
about the discussion about AI alignment
that it seems to be following these
status very much most people seem to be
in stage three also according to Robert
Keegan I think he says that about 85 of
people are in stage three and stay there
and if you're in stage four four or
three and your opinions are the result
of social assimilation then what you're
mostly worried about and the AI is that
the AI might have the wrong opinions so
if the AI is just something racist or
sexist we are all lost because we will
assimilate the wrong opinions from the
AI and so we need to make sure that the
AI has the right opinions and the right
values and the right structure and
if you're at stage four that's not your
main concern and so most nerds I don't
really worry about
um the
algorithmic bias and the model that it
picks up because if there's something
wrong with this bias the AI
automatically will prove it at some
point we'll get it there that it makes
mathematical proofs about reality and
then it will figure out what's true and
what's false but you're still worried
that AI might turn you into paper clips
because it might have the wrong values
right so if it's set up is there a wrong
function that controls its direction in
the world then it might do something
that is completely horrible and there's
no easy way to fix it so that's more
like a stage four rationalist kind of
worry and if you are at stage five
you're mostly worried that AI is not
going to be enlightened fast enough
because you realize that the game is not
so much about intelligence but about
agency about the ability to control the
future and the identity is instrumental
to this and if you are Are a Human Being
I think at some level you ought to
choose your own identity it's you should
not have somebody else pick the costume
for you and then wear it but instead you
should be mindful about what you want to
be in this world and I think if you are
an agent that is fully malleable that
can provide its own source code like an
AI might do at some point then the
identity that you will have is whatever
you can be
and
in this way the AI will maybe become
everything like a planetary control
system and if it does that then if we
want to coexist with it it means that it
will have to share purposes with us so
it cannot be a transactional
relationship we will not be able to use
reinforcement learning with human
feedback to hardwire its values into it
but this has to happen it's probably
that it's conscious so it can relate to
our own mode of existence where an
observer is observing itself in real
time and within certain temporal frames
and the other thing is that it probably
needs to have some kind of
transcendental orientation building
shared agency and in the same way as we
do when we are able to interrupt with
each other and to a non-transactional
relationships and I find that something
that because the Stage 5 is so rare is
is missing in much of the discourse and
I think that we need in some sense
focus on how to formalize love how to
understand love and how to build it into
the machines that we are currently
building and that are about to become
smarter than us